OK, so we're here at the
Nottingham Forest Football
Stadium, and we wanted
to find some
excuse to use the stadium.
So I thought, why not talk about
the football itself?
Now, it's a very special shape,
but I tell you what.
For the purpose of this video,
I'm going to use this little
toy version.
This is a bit clearer to see.
Now, this is actually a special
mathematical shape.
It's called a truncated
icosahedron.
But what is an icosahedron?
Let's start with that.
So this prop, slightly less
glamorous, I'm afraid.
It's a home-made prop.
I made it out of cardboard
myself.
But this is the icosahedron.
It has 20 triangular faces,
and it looks like this.
So now, if I cut off the
corners of this shape--
we have 12 corners.
If I cut them off, I will now
make my football shape, the
truncated icosahedron.
So the truncated icosahedron
has 12 pentagon faces.
Here they are in black.
And 20 hexagon faces.
There they are in white,
and they fit together.
And this is your traditional
football.
This was used in professional
games since the 1970s, and has
been more recently replaced
with a modern ball, which
actually uses fewer panels.
Now, there is an advantage,
though, to using the
old-fashioned ball.
Because although it's slightly
counter-intuitive, the
stitching around the ball makes
it a bit more rough.
It makes the surface a bit more
rough, and it actually
makes it more aerodynamic.
What they find within modern
balls, because they're
smoother and are less rough,
they are actually less
aerodynamic.
So they have to artificially
add dimples, and artificial
grooves, and stitching, so that
it will have the same
sort of flight as the
old-fashioned balls did.
Yeah, so this shape was also
used by an American architect
called Bookie Fuller.
He used to build domes
in this shape.
And it's him that they named
the Bookie Ball after.
The Bookie Ball is this shape.
Yeah, you may have heard
of the Bookie Ball.
It's also used in chemistry
because it's a molecule of 60
carbon atoms, again, forming
this shape, the truncated
icosahedron.
So in a Bookie Ball, we have
these 60 atoms, which are the
corners of this truncated
icosahedron shape, making the
same shape as this
football makes.